Okay, um, so I've been getting requests, um, of the
er that I should send a notes guys.
I, I, I lost all of my notes.
Um, I really apologize for that.
Um, I don't know if it's possible that you can like
maybe take the notes off the videos.
I don't know.
I don't know if that's possible.
I do not think about that,
that you guys would want notes.
Um, I'm really,
I'm truly sorry about that. Um,
so I really just hope you can,
um, take them off the videos,
pausing the videos.
I know it's a lot of work.
Um, but I really do not have,
I no longer have those notes anymore.
Um, I'm really,
I'm really sorry about that.
Um, so let's, uh,
continue on with our series guys.
Um, so we are currently, uh,
still doing road settlement.
I promise you today,
uh, we'll be done with settlements. Okay,
we are working today all the way to the end. Okay,
so are the road settlement issues, of course,
and we need to know, uh,
what's the problem? Okay,
what is it caused by?
Okay, and what is the solution?
Okay, so let's get right into it.
Okay, so the first, uh,
issue that we have,
um, is a issue of notal urban migration. Okay,
so what is rural urban migration?
You have to know the definition. Well,
this is simply, uh,
the movement. Okay,
migration is movement from one place to another.
So Rural urban meaning
which is a movement from rural areas to urban areas
okay, so of course
we want to understand why would people want to do that?
What's the reason behind that? Okay,
so the push and pull factors gives you the reason as to
er why are people moving from rural areas to
urban areas okay,
so start with the push factors
so push factors of course are the things or
the causes or the reasons why people are moving out
okay out of rural areas okay,
so of course
so those are your push factors
hope you guys do see this okay,
so these are factors forcing people out of rural areas
okay um so first of all is
few or lack of basic services okay,
so now we know that rural areas um
I do not have
have poor basic services
so we are talking about education guys okay,
so we know that
the state of schools in rural areas is very poor guys
health okay
so uh your your uh
your hospitals
your clinics uh
they are in very poor condition if they are there okay
um you'd find out it's a leg
or maybe there's a few of them
you'd have to maybe um
walk or or or travel a very er
er large distance to get there
so it's a struggle guys
er for people who are residing in rural areas
they do not have these services er
that er er that urban Areas offer okay,
there's a lack of job opportunities of course
so of course
we know that a vast majority of people
move from rural areas to urban areas
to look for better job opportunities
there's no jobs
there's no work
there's no companies
there's no there's few businesses
there's few investment there
and also there's lack of infrastructure as well
that's why businesses aren't going to open there okay,
this lack of infrastructure
it makes it difficult
to operate a business
um in such an area
where there is like no infrastructure
and you know
and you'd find that um
there's like a very complex
uh topography
and so it's very difficult to travel uh
with a car and would have to maintain it a lot
and of course
that cost a lot of money okay
um and you know
there's far
the services are far
like it's very difficult to even stock
er to restock
er in your business care
in your shops
so lack of job opportunities
that's why you have a lot of young people moving out
okay, lot of young people
are going to
urban areas okay
to look for better er
job opportunities okay,
there's poor infrastructure
okay of course
we talked about that
and because there's lack of investment there okay,
lack of investment guys
it really um
makes it difficult for
for the rural areas to develop okay,
cannot attract
any investor with a poor infrastructure
how can they operate there?
How Can they have their business there?
How can they put in their money
and hope that they will get profits
where you have a lot of barriers a lot of
things that actually make it difficult
to operate a business there okay,
like infrastructure is very important guys
to operating a business shop okay?
Um, in some areas
in some rural areas
there's this mechanization um,
that's on the rise
so people are being basically replaced by machines okay?
So in like even in agriculture now
you no longer need a lot of people because er,
you have technology
you have er
machines that can do the same job
and machines do not get tired guys and so
and and so it even might be er,
less costly to the business guy
er, that has employed you
it's less costly for him to to to, um,
to have a machine rather than you so it, it,
it would spend less money having a machine than
and employing you
so that this is becoming a real problem
so people can't get jobs
and because there's not a lot of shops,
there's not a lot of companies there
and people cannot even
and get employed in the agricultural sector
because they are being replaced by machine
so where do people go?
Of course they are going to move out um,
natural disasters, okay,
so, uh, drought,
okay, we, we know that uh,
it's a lot of trout because um,
you do not Have basic services guys. Water,
there's no water there. Okay,
there's lack of water guys.
It's social injustice.
We will talk about social uh,
justice issues by the way.
There's no water there.
It's uneven.
It's unequal guys
because you get these
er, er, er er,
you get even better quality of water
er in urban areas. Okay,
so natural disasters like drought,
you're flooding because you have rivers
so this again
of course affects the agricultural sector
of course people as well
of course now you have droughts, flooding,
people are going to get retrenched
people are going to get fired from
or rather retrenched because now you going to have er
all of your crops destroyed. Okay,
we can no longer produce
we can no longer operate as a business and so er,
we can no longer afford to employ people
and so we'll trench them.
Okay, so those are your push factors. Um,
I hope you do you,
you guys do write down as I'm like walking through with
with you, uh,
just you know
write down all these notes for for for
for you guys who want notes so you can write along um,
and maybe so a few of uh
few notes on the side
er, just to sort of like explain things
remember you guys can
you cannot just write lack of job opportunities
just try to make it a sentence guys like er,
try and show in geograph
you have to ensure that You explain, okay,
try to explain,
like you explaining,
um, to someone who,
who doesn't know, um,
uh, this, this,
this content. Okay.
Um, and then the pull factors,
of course, these are factors that are pulling or
attracting people into urban areas. Okay,
so attracting people that are living in rural areas,
er, so these are things that attract them to urban areas.
Okay. Why do they go to urban areas?
So access to better services. Okay,
there's better schools,
there's like,
there's better education
that there's better health care,
er, services.
There's better, er,
er, like there's electricity,
there's, um, water,
um, there's like shops a nearby.
So as you can see,
like I would
move from rural areas to urban areas because of this.
Okay, better service.